menia is a Syrian refugee from Aleppo
for three months she's been living in a
plastic sheet at home in a refugee camp
in zarley Lebanon Maya's parents
returned to Syria thinking they could
easily come back to Lebanon but now they
are stuck though leaving her at the age
of 15 to take care of three brothers
after the rent is paid on the plot of
land around her tent there's barely
enough left for heating or food though
today Maria I see one of the cams aid
workers has come to check on her she's
worried that Minaya and the 27 other
families here won't be able to survive
on the little cash they received from
the UN the refugees received a one-time
payment of forty dollars per child for
heating fuel when the winter began they
get an additional $21 per head each
month of food that Maria says families
need at least three hundred dollars a
month to survive with dignity maybe you
are asked for the minimum but even under
the minimum of fifty percent for us we
are looking for those children that for
if if continue like this maybe
malnutrition will happen maybe health
infection will happen with her three
brothers two take care of each day is
such a challenge from ania
I do all the chores I come in the house
I cook for my siblings we get a blue
card from the UN and it's not enough
they give us one hundred dollars me
dinner and sometimes we are forced to
get the bread from the neighbor her
neighbors are also struggling though to
cope all three are ill due to the toxic
fumes from using plastic as a fuel just
to stay warm leaving a burning question
for Lebanon's UNICEF boss is it a
funding crisis um I think there is
insufficient funds absolutely there is
increased funds coming into the into the
country to support these programs but
ultimately it's not reaching the levels
that it has to none of these families
here actually imagine they'll be living
in such poverty after fleeing the war in
neighboring Syria badly and gets all the
elements are now health concerns the
last thing these people need is a
compromise to their lifeline and now
with this new UN funding crisis the real
worry is the gap between what the UN
gets what it actually needs remains the
same or even widens